in other net neutrality news there is
going to be a Senate vote on restoring
net neutrality wow that's fantastic
headlines yesterday people just loving
it cheering in the streets well not in
the streets but I mean it's cold in
Massachusetts anyway they're probably
doing most of the cheering indoors but
it's not going to pass Democrat and
Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer
says they're gonna have a vote on
putting back the Internet freedom
provisions that the FCC recently
destroyed from the Obama era Schumer
says hey we can bring this to a vote in
the Senate we can force a vote without
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell's
approval there's this legal and
procedural precedent called the
Congressional review Act or CRA and it
was enacted under none other than House
Speaker Newt Gingrich later signed into
law by Bill Clinton and what this allows
Congress to do is as the name suggests
review and if they want to overrule
legislation in an expedited manner but
this is incredibly unlikely to get net
neutrality of the net neutrality undoing
overruled
because even after doug jones is seated
in the senate which will be in the next
legislative session in January democrats
will still be at a fifty one to forty
nine disadvantage they'll be at a major
disadvantage in the house of
representatives and it's just not
looking like republicans are going to
vote on the side of good on this one and
also even if they did donald trump could
veto it if it passed so it's not going
to happen
so what perfectly fair question is what
are democrats doing what is the point of
this and I think that one advantage one
possibility of what they might be doing
is getting their votes on the record in
favor of net neutrality in advance of
the 2018 midterms but also getting
Republicans on the record opposing that
neutrality again for campaign purposes
and you could hear me say that and say
David that that's a waste of time by our
elected officials but you could also
hear me say it and say that's a good
idea
because of the real way that we're going
to undo this is by voting them out and
if you believe that the only way to
reinstate net neutrality is by voting
them out
than anything you can do to justify
voting them out is a good thing you feel
strongly one way or the other political
stunts or useful I'm actually more
optimistic than you are on this because
I think enough Senate Republicans will
just vote present or not vote at all on
this one because they don't want to be
on the record as opposed to net
neutrality sure so maybe you can take
those 49 Democrats maybe add in John
Thune from South Dakota he's been in
favor of net neutrality yes there's
there's hope I think in this one but
then there's the house yes so that yeah
I mean maybe again you could get maybe
the PR of saying hey the Senate said put
it back but it is effectively a moot
point in terms of actually reinstating
it and then who knows what President
Trump would do to with his opinion on
that neutrality no one knows yeah he
says it's the Fairness Doctrine that
that was one of trumps comments that new
net neutrality is the Fairness Doctrine
so don't hold your breath for Trump to
explain to us what this is but you can
probably assume Trump would veto it if
the CRA resulted in trying to reinstate
net neutrality in the meantime
Republicans flailing now talking about
half measures of their own Republicans
now apparently might propose their own
bill which wouldn't restore net
neutrality but it would ban ISPs from
throttling traffic but it would still
allow paid prioritization and the way
Republicans have been operating under
Trump I wouldn't be shocked if their
bill included a repeal of Obamacare
because obviously if you reinstate a
piece of net neutrality it makes perfect
sense to repeal Obamacare or maybe even
ban abortion while they're at it yeah I
mean the mandates going down with this
new tax plan so with this new net
neutrality bill maybe they can get rid
of the subsidies perhaps and a lot of
people don't know that by the way that
there is there is Obamacare related
stuff in the tax bill we'll talk about
the tax bill later I will say this we
should have net neutrality written into
the law as opposed to being subject to
the whims of each administration through
the FCC so if this stunt helps Democrats
take over the House and Senate in 2018
or maybe 2020 and actually makes net
neutrality part of the law rather than
subject to the FCC's political bent that
would be a very good thing send me your
thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
we'll take a break
major program for you today glad that
you're with us today
sponsor is live lingua with the free
trial at live lingua dot-com slash
Pakman the bottom line is this your
relatives don't need any more wine
openers or appetizer dishes that they're
just going to put in a cabinet if you're
looking for a gift that your friends and
family will love and actually use
consider the gift of learning a new
language immersive language sessions
with live lingua are a great way for you
to give the most memorable and most
meaningful holiday gifts this year gift
cards are available at live lengua comm
slash Paquin live lingua doesn't offer
some trendy new gimmick where in five
minutes a day you'll be fluent in a new
language in a month they take the proven
approach to getting students of language
fluent and confident in one of the 11
most widely spoken languages in the
world and their immersive language
program and learning methods are the
same ones that diplomats and educators
have used for a very very long time and
you work on Skype one-on-one with your
teacher no concerns about falling behind
in class nor about getting stuck in
traffic driving to your next lesson and
this is a method that is going to
increase memorization and make a new
language be a part of your life and this
holiday season our listeners and viewers
have a one-up on gift-giving you can go
to live language comm slash Pakman to
get the gift cards you also qualify for
the free first lesson and don't worry
they will not say anything if the gift
is actually for you go to live lingua
comm /p a que ma n for the free trial
and to learn more